[Music]
the one and only and that would be the
one and only Lady Gaga who gave hundreds
of little monsters
so thrill of a lifetime when she
surprised them at a screening in New
York on a star is born and of course doc
I made a fabulous entrance and a sparkly
red turtleneck dress and black boots and
she thanked all of her fans and her
co-star Bradley Cooper who also directed
the movie now a star is born it hits
theaters tomorrow so an honor that well
we're throwing it back to when Bradley
was just grinding star
we actually have your very first
interview that you did really what year
was that one for - those were those for
Haley's yeah good memory Oh Cheryl shows
the alias yeah I'm totally totally blown
away it's hot it's like sexy it's
pumping it's incredible
from the frosted tips to the cream color
to suit Bradley has come a long way
since that very first et interview new
life Bradley's first TV appearance was
in a 1999 episode of Sex in the City
he was everything I was looking for that
night single straight and a smoker two
years later he landed his first film
role in the indie cult comedy wet hot
American summer we'll meet again and
we'll see what kind of people we've
blossomed into I just graduated school
two days before I came out here so
having the opportunity to work on a film
was something I would jump at 2009 the
hangover would ultimately make Cooper a
household name
there were nights we'll never forget
I just say yeah yeah four Oscar
nominations and one sexiest men alive
cover later it's hard to believe he
wasn't always thought of as a handsome
leading man
the feedback was you're not really you
have to have thick skin it's definitely
not for everybody and I've heard
everything everything
[Music]
[Applause]